استهداف في مخيم النصيرات في هذه اللحظات
طائرات الاحتلال الحربيه اغارت على هذا
المنزل قصفت هذا المنزل بعدد من الصواريخ
عداد من الاصابات عداد من العالقين في هذا
المنزل طواقم الانقاظ كذلك طواقم الاسعاف
وصلت في هذه اللحظات لمحاوله اطفاء هذا
الحريق وانتشال مزيدا من المصابين من هذا
المنزل
المستهدف هؤلا الطواقم طواقم الاطفاء
الذين يفتقرون الى ادنى المعدات حتى
خراطيم المياه التي نشاهدها هي ممزقه
وممزق المنقذ او حتى رجل الارفاق
استخدامها بشكل جيد الامكانيات ضعيفه جدا
ويعني بشتغلوا
باظافرهم بدون اي معدات او اي اغراض مخصصه
للدفع
المدني الشهداء هنا يتم انتشالهم من هذا
المنزل انتشال عدد من الشهداء في هذا
المنزل
[موسيقى]
المستهدف الاهالي
لام الشهداء
هنا انتشال
الاعداد جديده من الشهداء
هنا
في استهداف منزل عائله حمدان يتم انتشال
عداد من الشهداء في هذه اللحظ اشلاء
وشهداء يتم
انتشالهم في هذه
اللحظات حتى اللحظه
طواقم الاسعاف والانقاذ تحاول هنا الشبان
يعثرون على اشلاء الشهداء
في هذا
المكان
المستهدف